can we almost like as a case study look
at a few people in the tech area that
i'm familiar with and i know well
we can the only caveat being that i may
have no familiarization with them
whatsoever you may have to brief me on
them yeah
so i'll do my best to brief the i'll do
my best to reduce
human beings into simple descriptions
and then you can give me insights of why
the hell they're such effective leaders
uh based on my description not based on
your actual deep knowledge of the
human beings uh so uh
that caveat of my inability to speak
both the english language and describe
humans
well let's talk about first elon musk
so he's known as being quite
harsh in the sense of first of all
a very high bar of excellence
and uh also willing to what he calls the
kind of first principles thinking
of asking the the questions that hurt
which is why the hell are we doing it
this way
why can't it be done a lot but not just
better but a lot better
so so let's i don't want to hear his
whole character i'll go one at
one section at a time so we got a guy
that's harsh yeah
and and asking the really hard questions
how can that be good or why is that good
well first of all it can be horrible and
there's leaders out there that are harsh
and they're hated and no one likes them
and no one wants to work for them and
they never do anything
so what is it that elon musk does that
makes gives him the ability to be harsh
so i was
i was hearing a description
of me yeah when i would give feedback
to young seals that had made mistakes
during training operations and
the description was that same thing like
this
harsh blunt force trauma
and just totally direct
sledgehammer of truth that i would hit
guys with
but it's interesting because i always
talk about you know building
relationships and making sure you're not
offending someone
yeah so how do these things match up
well i can tell you how they match up
when i was being harsh the guys that i
was being harsh
with knew without one shred of doubt
that i cared about them more than
anything else and that the reason i was
giving them this feedback is because i
wanted them to be able to lead their
troops i wanted
them to be able to go accomplish their
mission and i wanted them to be able to
bring their guys home
from war so i wasn't being harsh because
it elevated my ego i wasn't being harsh
because i wanted to
denigrate them i was being actually
being harsh because i wanted them to
accomplish the mission
so if that's where elon comes from
hey listen we got to make this happen
this is for this is for the good of the
world to do this
and people know that then it works
i'll bring this point back up with
another guy steve jobs but let me stay
on elon for a second
the uh the other thing he does which is
interesting i'm
i see the value of this it'd be great to
hear you
uh speak about it is unlike many of the
other ceos
very rich billionaires uh
you know involved in leading a lot of
people he
puts a lot of time into making sure he's
on the factory floor
he famously sleeps on the sort of like
in the middle of things
and he puts a lot of effort he's also
very good at it
is being a low-level engineer so like
whatever the task is
he wants to understand the details and
he'll talk to
the lowest level person in terms of like
you know somebody who's
like uh working literally on putting
parts together
he wants to understand what the problem
is what the challenge is if there's an
emergency he wants to understand the
actual details of the problem not like
delegating into a manager but like
because a lot of ceos a lot of managers
will will talk about sort of the the
power and the importance of delegation
here he wants to know if there's a big
problem he wants to know the exact
detail
he wants to know the exact problem he
wants to at the fundamental level
understand how to solve that problem
whether it has to do with materials
whether it has to do with the actual
manufacturing the
uh mechanical engineering aspect like
we're talking about like engineering
this is a guy who wears a suit there's a
ceo
tweets about deutsche coin but like an
actual job he's low-level engineering
and that to me was always inspiring to
see somebody who knows
what the [ __ ] they're doing that's what
it like he gains the respect
of engineers at the lowest level
i don't know if that's scalable but
that's always been inspiring to me and i
wonder
how many people it's inspiring to maybe
you can speak to the value of doing that
of no matter how high your level of
leader is to be able to do the low level
[ __ ]
yeah and that's that's a common trait
that good leaders have
and maybe he doesn't necessarily know
how to do everything a good leader
but they go down there and talk to the
front line troops and say
hey what is the issue that you're
dealing with or
you know how can i support you how can i
give you help and what one key point
that you said is he said when there's a
problem
he gets in there so there's things
happening at his companies that
they're working and so he doesn't have
to die i'm not saying he never does but
he doesn't have to spend as much time
working on
or looking at some sub-system that's
functioning well
he's got a good leader in there that's
handling it and he checks in with that
leader and the leader says yeah it's
working perfectly he says great
that when there's a problem but that's
when he might have to get down there and
dig into some details so that he fully
understands it so that he
when he digs down on the details and
this is important
he's coming from an altitude where he
has a
better bigger perspective not
necessarily better but a bigger
perspective
so if you sit there and work on a
problem whatever
for eight hours and you're staring at
you know if you were planning a mission
and you were you were planning it for
eight hours you're staring at the
the maps and the charts and you're
figuring out where all the troops are
gonna be located
and i come in after eight hours and i
look at your plan
from a from a distant perspective
there's a good chance i'll be able to
see
holes in your plan that you couldn't see
because your perspective was too close
so so that's good for me to be able to
come in from a higher perspective and
have a look at it
but also there's times where
i need to get down there and actually
look you know if you're looking at a
problem you say look i can't figure out
boss i can't figure out how to get to
this target
and i'm looking at it from a distance
and i don't see i might need to start
digging in
and looking and saying oh here's a route
that we can take that actually makes
sense
let's try that so i think it's a good
example
of someone going up and down
in altitude to look at problems
understanding what's happening with the
frontline troops and at the same time
being able to go back
to the strategic level and i can it's
probably this way
the reason that he's successful is
because he doesn't get stuck down there
yeah because if he felt the need to
micromanage each and every part
on a tesla it wouldn't be
it would be very unlikely that he would
have the capacity to do all that
now he can hand over some broad
chip design and say hey this is what the
function needs to be and he gives it to
lex and lex goes there with your team
and you figured out and you make it
happen
if he had to actually do that all
himself most likely not possible
so that's what leaders should be doing
they should go elevate
and and and and then get down in the
weeds when they have to
and then go back up the sad thing
this is the part that makes me not want
to do a startup
is uh basically his whole life is
dealing with emergencies
just like you said he's not dealing
this is not shooting the [ __ ] about
details of engineering
it's dealing with like in this in the
case of the company
life and death like something that can
just
completely damage the production line
right so he's constantly dealing with
emergencies putting out fires
and um i don't know if there's something
to be said about the psychology of that
of how uh like he he's spoken himself
that he's worried
whether his mind can hold up much longer
so hopefully in the near future he will
start to
form more decentralized command where he
has some subordinate leadership
that he fully trusts and most important
that he has properly
trained so that they can handle these
day-to-day fires
at least 80 percent of them so only 20
of the time does he actually need to go
in and solve a problem
if he's not doing that right now then
that's going to end up being a problem
anytime so i work with companies all the
time and that's what's interesting about
this is
i go and work with a ceo or with a with
the c-suite of a company
it takes a little while to figure out
what's going on i'm kind of going off of
the things that you're telling me yeah
almost anecdotally right yes but
let's say that what you and also i don't
know how familiar
you actually are with the inner workings
of his companies
but if we were to assume that what
you're saying is accurate
then my advice would be hey listen you
need to start putting a little bit more
time and effort into training up some
subordinate leadership that has the
trust knowledge and expertise that you
will be able to turn over
some of these some of these details too
for two reasons number one so you can
let your brain um you know you can you
can survive a little longer as he put it
but also all the time that you spend as
a leader looking down and
into your organization it's time that
you're not looking up and out
so when you're not looking up and out
you're not seeing what the competitor's
doing you're not seeing where the
market's going there's problems that
that can come from that so if right now
he's spending too much time looking down
and in
and you mentioned you know you said i
don't know if i want to do a startup
when you do a startup you're going to be
looking down and in for a while yeah
it's going to take a while you're going
to have to do all this work yourself
you're not going to have the finances to
put
people manpower behind these things so
that's probably he maybe he's in that
mindset a little bit because he's done
so many startups over the years and so
he's in the
he's habitually in the weeds
so my advice would be all right let's
start looking at formulating some
subordinate leadership that has the like
i said the expertise the trust that you
can
you can start to turn over some of these
more
minut details to them so that you can
start looking up and out
yeah i think he's done that more
successfully in some places than others
the spacex a lot of people give
the credit to gwen shawwal for the ceo
uh the ceo of spacex as
as a very successful person that runs
[ __ ] but
in tesla not as much so i wonder if you
can comment on
something a lot of people worry about
and this applies to a lot of tech
companies
which is a lot of people worry about
that if elon disappears
the the innovative spirit the company is
as we know them today will collapse
will stagnate and will basically fail to
do what they've been doing for so many
years successfully
is there some aspect to uh what makes a
good leader that
if you disappear it's still
the thing still lives on and not just
lives on but thrives
yeah so what we have to do in those
situations is we have to establish
a strong culture inside that
organization
and if you're there's there's reasons
why this happens right
if i have a big ego and i form a company
and
i love the fact that everyone looks at
me and says oh jocko made this company
and
he's the creative force behind this
company and that fuels my ego and it
makes me feel good
and you know i'm working with you lex
and every time you come up with an idea
i say lexi you need to stay in your box
yeah
right so i'm not creating a culture that
rewards
that sort of creativity and eventually
when i die
i won't have educated my team
on how to maintain that creative aspect
so
again hopefully inside that organization
he's he's encouraging and growing that
culture
where creativity is rewarded where where
it flourishes even when he's gone that's
what we have to hope for
yeah yeah he he is but i also
seem to notice that there's not many
people like him
people become complacent
too easily at this point i've been
disappointed by people a little bit
it's like success makes people soft
now with elon it seems like success
doesn't have any effect that's like the
reverse effect
it doesn't it's like what's the it's
always like what's the next bigger thing
right he's living that exponential
growth
which i think that's the problem that
you have to have somebody who's
constantly trying to find the 10x
solution like trying to constantly
improve things
and uh restlessly that i mean that
probably has to do with
finding the right people not just
creating the culture but creating the
culture
with the rights of people
you